[Musique]
bonjour et eu mon meilleur ami ils ont
mené les meilleurs amis mais les
meilleurs c'est merveilleux je pense que
tu qui a fait quelque chose
lundi si tu sais quoi que ce soit vaut
mieux que tu me le disent y'a un truc
qui va pas j'ai dit ok
ce qui est un souhait
ce qui c'est toi quel fils à jo display
la poupée du mal au cinéma le 19 juin
bonjour j'ai eu mon meilleur ami est bon
mais mes meilleures amies mes meilleurs
je pense que tu qu'ils avaient dit si tu
sais quoi que ce soit vaut mieux que tu
me le disent y'a un truc qui va pas
choquer
ce qui est un souhait
ce qui c'est toi qui le fuit sa voix
s'amuse bien
jsb la coupe et du mal au cinéma le 19
juin